mesdames et messieurs regina king
live tv c'est parti bienvenue
aux 93e oscars
ce fut en effet une année difficile pour tout le monde
mais
notre amour des films nous a aidés à nous
en sortir
nous a fait nous sentir moins isolés et
nous a connectés
quand nous étions séparés huey p newton bobby
sceller
la fête de la panthère noire ils m'ont montré
comment m'aimer le
pouvoir de l'unité que quand ils jouent
diviser pour régner
nous disons s'unir et monter mec
mec c'est bon et l'oscar va
à christopher hampton et florian
zeller
le père anthony hopkins
j'ai écrit le script pour  lui, euh pour moi, il
est le plus grand, le plus grand
acteur vivant et juste l'idée de travailler avec lui
était comme un rêve et je savais que ce
n'était pas un rêve facile à réaliser parce que
je suis français comme vous pouvez l'entendre  juste
je n'ai pas de mots je suis tellement tellement tellement
heureux et reconnaissant
et tant que je suis debout je vais toujours
me battre pour nous je vais toujours me
battre
pour mon peuple et me battre pour ce qui est juste
et  je pense que c'est ce que fait la musique et c'est ce
que fait la narration alors merci
beaucoup merci
et l'oscar va à
jejung yoon
enfin où étiez-vous pendant que nous
tournions
à tulsa très honorés de vous rencontrer
merci beaucoup et j'aimerais  merci
à
mes deux garçons qui m'ont fait sortir
et travailler
c'est le résultat parce que maman a travaillé
si dur que
je ne connaissais pas la danse mais
savez-vous comment faire la tortue de quête des fesses
allez voyons voyons laisse-moi voir à travers les
fesses  voyez-le
[Applaudissements]
et l'oscar va à la
gloire de la terre nomade
les gens à la naissance sont intrinsèquement bons
et ces six lettres ont eu un si grand
impact sur moi quand j'étais enfant
et je les crois toujours vraiment aujourd'hui
s'il vous plaît
regardez notre film sur le plus grand écran
possible
et un jour, très très bientôt, emmenez tous ceux que
vous connaissez
dans un théâtre au coude à coude dans
cet espace sombre
et regardez tous les films qui sont représentés
ici ce soir,
nous donnons celui-ci à notre loup
[Applaudissements]